it is August 2nd 2023 and time for
another monthly update video I'm a
little bit under the weather which is
why I didn't do this yesterday and I
actually had to skip an event that I
would have been doing tonight talking
about David Hume which was going to be
put off to November but I'm on the mend
and so I can tell you about what we did
in July what we've got coming up in
August and I always like to begin by
talking about three big things that I'd
like to put on your radar big thing
number one is that the half hour Hegel
series
is probably going to come to a close at
least for those who are patreon
supporters of the project in August I've
got five more videos left to shoot I
haven't publicly released all of the
videos that I shot this last month but I
created 5 over them some were they're
always early released to patreon
supporters and then to the general
public but you you've seen me cross the
800 paragraph threshold so there's not
that much left to go in the project big
thing number two if you've been
following me in social media or also
here on YouTube you've seen pictures of
the cats that I've been posting in the
almost home cat shelter here in
Milwaukee
and I've gone through the volunteer
training which also included a really
good online class about fear-free
shelters so I am going to be
volunteering regularly now at almost
home that means
um helping to be there for the open
houses that I've been going to coming in
on off days to feed and water and and
take care of the other needs of the cats
that are there and sometimes
volunteering at local events a big thing
number three I also got asked recently
to take on some additional classes for
the Fall by Marquette University so I'm
going to be teaching once again for
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
and for Marquette University I've got a
full load of four classes introduction
to Humanities foundations of philosophy
business ethics and ethics for artists
and designers so a lot of big things on
the horizon now let's talk about July we
had a full complement of the usual
monthly events in July I did my AMA
that's asked me anything session we had
our Hegel q a and discussion sessions I
also did the worlds of speculative
fiction focusing on CL Moore and the GRL
of jury stories I did a self-directed
study Sadler's advice on David Hume and
of course we had our wisdom for Life
radio show we got at least one episode
in uh it's been a little bit sporadic
the production of these but fortunately
we've got plenty of episodes always we
can err on the the uh the radio station
at the usual time and I did an
interesting event called conversations
with modern stoicism where I was talking
about why stoics ought to care about bad
things happening to other people even if
from a stoic perspective strictly
speaking they might not be bad things
they're still bad to those people and so
you can see videos for all of these I've
got them listed and linked to below you
can see in the video description or the
click here to show more I also did a
good bit of writing in my medium
Publications you can see those and I've
been doing a considerable amount of
class preparation which is quite
important as well
and uh I did the volunteer training and
I've been hiking quite a bit at Lapham
Peak State Park which is one of my
favorite places to go you may have seen
some of the pictures from there as well
video work
um I got five half hour Hegel videos
done last month which is a pretty uh
good production for for me
um just five more most likely to go I
also did a book review on Simon Drewes
the poet and the sage I did a caption
contest video which some of you
participated in I also released a fake
quotes video about Epictetus that has
drawn a lot of interest I also did a
update video about my own experience and
and you know living with depression
that's gotten a lot of views a lot of
comments so you might want to check that
out did some Sadler telling stories uh
videos one of which was prompted by my
wife Andy and I going to my 35th year
class reunion for high school which was
quite interesting I did a lot of
um speculative fiction studies videos on
Philip K Dix the man in the High Castle
and finished that series and then I did
one long overdue video on philosophy as
a way of philosophy understood as a way
of life in my philosophical developments
and phases series that gives you an idea
about what it is that I'm committed to
as a philosopher I was pretty busy with
the podcast as well
finished up the series on Marcus
aurelius's meditations there were still
a few left to release and then I went
through all of uh tolkiens on fairy
stories there were 11 podcast episodes
in that series and uh then switched to
Philip K dick one of his great speeches
the Android and the human there's four
episodes on that and then I've been
releasing episodes on Robert Audi's
virtue ethics as a resource in business
which is a really great article that I
actually use in some of my classes and
we'll be recommending to my business
ethics and my ethics for Artisan
designers students coming up this
semester so that's that's July
a lot of events coming up in August and
all of these are in Central Time most of
them are online so you can participate
in them quite easily but you got to make
sure that you show up on time I do have
people sometimes getting them mixed up
and showing up at the end of the hour
rather than the top of the hour for some
of these events so on the fifth at noon
I will be having my monthly AMA that's
ask me anything session where you can do
that you can ask me about philosophy my
personal life my interest in music you
know the cats that I'm I'm checking out
and and taking care of or any of that
sort of stuff then later that afternoon
for
patreon supporters at the ten dollar
level I'll have my monthly philosophy
chat which is a much more intimate
setting allowing for
um you know video conferencing rather
than just you know answering comments
and stuff like that
on the sixth or the following day at 11
A.M I will be doing a storytelling with
with Sadler and I'm going to be talking
about or actually reading one of my
favorite short stories by Ursula K lean
one that I think is very important for
understanding the Earth sea stuff and
it's called the rule of names and
there's a Twist to it so I won't tell
you what it is but it's it's quite cool
on the 9th at 5 PM we'll have our
monthly public Hegel q a and discussion
sessions so you can pop in and ask
questions about Hegel
that is underwritten by the supporters
of the half hour higgle project on the
12th at noon we will be having worlds of
speculative fiction and this will be
session 72 it's going to be on JG
Ballard who we've done before but now
we're looking at his three worlds novels
the uh drowned World The Burning world
now it's called the drought it was it
was redone and then the crystal world
and these are very very timely and
interesting pieces that were written in
in the 60s
and you can join us for that we'll have
you know video premiere where you can do
live chat and I'll be talking about all
sorts of important aspects of World
building and philosophical themes and
then we'll do
a zoom conference uh talking about it in
further detail on the 17th we actually
leave now this is not something you can
participate in but I think you might
find it interesting
uh originally my my wife had planned for
us a whole birthday weekend because my
birthday is the 18th of August and we
were going to go out to Eau Claire
Wisconsin
and see armored Saint and then wasp uh
perform live which is going to be a
great show unfortunately Blackie Lawless
injured his back and so that is is put
off but the big surprise was that we
were going to be stopping at a big cat
Refuge where you actually get to like
stay on site and in the morning help
feed the big cats something that uh I
think my wife has had you know going in
the back of her mind for for a very long
time she knows how much I like big cats
as well as little cats and so this is
going to be quite cool we're still going
to do that we're just not going to go
out for the concert but we're gonna
check out the cats and um yeah we'll see
what it's like right okay
we won't be lions and tigers and bears
but it'll be lions and tigers and
cougars and lynxes and stuff like that
on the 19th we'll be back here in
Milwaukee and at noon I will be doing
the next understanding anger 2.0 session
um we're going to be looking at anger in
Aristotle's Nick and McCann and your
Damian ethics and the politics and the
Poetics and a few other works like the
topics and parts of animals
we did a session on Aristotle's rhetoric
which is where he discusses anger in the
most depth but there's all sorts of
other things that he has to say quite
important in his Works Aristotle is the
first person in the west to sort of
scientifically look at anger as a
psychologist
on the 25th here in Milwaukee at the
Women's Club of Wisconsin I will be
doing another philosophy eats and this
is sort of a dinner with uh some mineral
remarks made by me and some discussion
about uh philosophical topics this time
we're going to be talking about the
Socratic method so that should be quite
interesting
and then on the 26th at noon we're going
to do another self-directed study video
I haven't decided yet who I'm going to
pick for that so
um you know I'm looking at the areas
that or the philosophers rather that I
most need to get to I think in order to
give people useful advice that they can
use and which is also feasible for me in
this very busy month as we lead up to
classes
video work
um I'm going to be hopefully finishing
up the half hour Hegel series uh you
probably won't see all of those videos
released to the public unless I really
step up the releases uh but if you're a
patreon supporter of the project you'll
see all of them and we'll probably do
some sort of event you know to
commemorate the series at some point I
got a couple more book reviews to do I
also have some ideas that matter uh
conversations interviews that I'm going
to be doing I've already recorded one
for this month and there'll be other
ones as well coming up
um I'm gonna do another fake quote so
I'm hoping on Seneca because there's
quite a few floating out there I'll
probably do some personal videos you
know some Sadler stories and some quick
takes and then uh I do have a caption
contest that I started you know maybe
I'll repost it because we didn't get
quite as many responses as I was hoping
for yet but it's a really cute picture
with Magnus our dog laying on top of
Sassy the cat or partially laying on her
and we'll we'll make that into a caption
contest video Once once we get enough
good responses and then uh core concept
videos so I won't be doing speculative
fiction videos this month instead I'm
going to be doing core concept videos
some of which I've been meaning to do
for a long time like the ones on Aquinas
is five ways some of which I pledged to
do last month but didn't get to like a
manual cons prologomina which we
probably won't get completely done this
month that'll probably drag on into
September but definitely a text that we
we need to do so
that's the video work
um podcast we're you know in the process
of releasing Robert Audi's uh
um virtue ethics as a resource and
business podcast episodes as I mentioned
before I I'm also taking the
um speculative fiction studies on Ursula
k laguines a wizard of Earthsea and
turning those into podcast episodes
those are kind of long you know around
20 minutes each so that's taking me a
little while to edit got some business
ethics stuff that we're going to be
doing as well including Milton
Friedman's the social responsibility of
business and then I will probably be if
I if I have the time be doing some on
Aristotle's categories
and my classes will begin in August my
academic classes
um Marquette begins a week after
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
and uh Milwaukee Institute of Art and
Design begins I believe on the 22nd
which is a Monday so I'm already going
to be you know Midway through the month
uh teaching face to face once again my
whole schedule is going to have to shift
around quite a bit but I'm looking
forward to the semester ahead I hope you
can join me for at least some of these
online events as I mentioned below
as I mentioned earlier rather if you
click show more or video description
you'll see links to all of this sort of
stuff another reminder as well if you're
going to come to the events make sure
you know what time zone you're in I'm in
Central Time and so unless you're in
central time you're left to do a little
bit of time enjoy adjustment but I hope
you have a great month ahead and I will
see you somewhere in these online events
or you know who knows maybe I'll see
some of you face to face here in the
Milwaukee region